round seven of the London chess classic  the last stop on the grand chest tour  after an exciting round six the best  chess players in the world came once  again in a fighting mood looking to see  who would be the one to move up the  leaderboard Grantchester leader Wesley  so tried to take down the big Russian  Vladimir Kramnik but perfect defense by  the former world champion steered the  game to a quiet draw keeping the  tournament leader from breaking away  from the pack the mercurial Hikaru  Nakamura bravely attacked neither  specialist maxing by sheila grog and his  opening preparation paid off as he blew  the Frenchman off the board to once  again draw himself into contention for  first place in the event is to pronounce  in the ground with a mad race to the  finish line round eight of the  season-ending classic coming up next  [Music]